[Música]
gracias como están me imagino un poco
cansados pero bueno espero hacerlo algo
dinámico algo interactivo y que sea
sobre todo entendible que es lo más
importante a ver quién es de ustedes se
acuerdan la primera vez que tuvieron
experiencias con la computadora con la
computación perdón os puedo ver porque
tiene que sacarme
se acuerdan alguien bueno me imagino que
la mayoría de ustedes no porque
prácticamente han nacido con la
tecnología
para mí bueno fue un hecho que marcó la
vida y algo que marcó la vida por
ejemplo fue el tatarabuelo de la memoria
flashes que nos conocen
el disco de 5 pulgadas
a efecto y yo también a ver quién tiene
por ahí uno
bueno aunque no es el original es una
maqueta porque lamentablemente he
preguntado a todo el mundo y nadie lo
tiene pueden creer eso el tatarabuelo de
la memoria flash os presento señores
habrá sido limitado todos estos cosas
pero es algo que cambió nuestra vida
nuestra manera de ver en realidad la
tecnología no
y empecé a trabajar en la final a fines
de la década de los 80 con la
computadora con una cual justamente con
una ibm que bueno era bastante difícil
poder acceder a los programas justamente
porque porque todo tienes que entrar
bajo comandos comandos de programación
para entrar a usar cada uno de estos
programas pero yo no teníamos una
computadora justamente por lo costoso
que costaba en esas épocas tenía que ir
el fin de semana una manera de
acompañarlo metió al banco los bancos
recién tenían estos ordenadores y
empezar a jugar y me decía centro así
que de esta manera que esto que el otro
y bueno fue un hecho que marcó mi vida
porque en realidad como podría influir
tus ideas a partir de unos comandos tour
podías visualizar en el monitor y luego
con una simple impresión podías tener
justamente lo que tú habías pensado fue
un hecho que marcó mi vida pero nunca me
imaginé que en realidad ese hecho bueno
ahora actualmente como dependemos de
toda esta tecnología
bueno ya en el colegio nos promovían
justamente el uso de la computación
bueno estaba bien como para sacarse una
foto listo pero nos insistían en el
colegio poder aprender el sistema
binario
con una manera de transferencia y
almacenamiento de la información
no había que reducir un montón de
fórmulas ecuaciones para ver como altea
se trabajaba con eso y era muy algo muy
análogo análogo con lo que pasaba no
hace mucho tiempo con el código código
morse con usted la grafistas justamente
para transferir la información a partir
de dos códigos
poder hacer la transferencia de esa
información que uno deseaba que uno
quería a pesar que mi abuelo trabajara
telegrafista tampoco fue un hecho que
promovió que me motivó a seguir
indagando estudiando
no creo que hacer computación o trabajar
con la informática estaba bien como para
sacarse la foto como les había mostrado
ya
cómo
luego leía en la universidad con los
ahorros que esas épocas mi madre pudo
pudo contar pudo justamente juntar me
compró una computadora a partir de esta
computadora bueno alguno se debe
identificar y pensé que este hecho iba a
cambiar mi manera de pensar de ser
productivo ya estando la universidad
porque un colegio hasta cierta manera me
sentía algo en desventaja porque ya
había compañeros que podían tener una
computadora se los veía mucho más
eficientes al realizar tareas o
investigaciones de ese tipo de cosas y
yo no tenía bueno llegué a pensar hasta
cierto punto como que me sentía en
desventaja con todo esto ese tipo de
proceso no pero ya teniendo la
computadora a un 95 dije genial mamá te
agradezco mucho ahora si no voy a tener
límites en mi progreso de mi carrera
profesional así que empecé a trabajar a
exigir más a la computadora pero luego
me di cuenta que me estaba metiendo otro
tipo de limitaciones a nivel de la
capacidad de la velocidad con la que
podía procesar la información
se me llenaba rápidamente el disco y lo
más grave para mí era poder acceder a
los programas muchos los programas
tenías que pagarlos estar bajo una
licencia justamente no podíamos pagar
fácilmente con la tarjeta de crédito que
hoy en día hasta que las tarjetas de
débito ya funcionan para pagar no podía
no había muchos programas de código
abierto esos que están disponibles
libres no había así que empecé a
frustrarme con la computación decía no
para qué para qué voy a trabajar para
qué voy a seguir indagando que les no
está informática no es lo mío así como
como biólogo me fui especializando a lo
que es la ecología no con la ecología yo
dije genial
hasta aquí llegó mi experiencia con las
computadoras yo voy a prefiero trabajar
con la naturaleza con el campo
interactuar con los medios me
especialicé la ecología acuática que es
la ecología bueno estudiar la
interacción justamente de los organismos
con su medio con su entorno así que toma
un montón de variables ambientales
recauda la cantidad de agua los
compuestos dos nutrientes que están
disueltos en el agua los mismos
dichos peces invertebrados que se
relacionaban a los llevado laboratorio
genial pero también me di cuenta que
tenía otro tipo de limitaciones a pesar
que no eran exclusivamente por la
computación pero llegaba a acumular un
montón de datos información hojas tras
hojas tras hojas lo tenía forzosamente
que llevar a un programa de una base de
datos para poder organizar diferentes
celdas columnas que tú pero y ahora qué
hago con esto me empecé a introducir a
lo que es los análisis estadísticos al
análisis multivariado y esos análisis en
esas épocas me permitieron poder resumir
esa información
así que con todos los datos
empecé justamente a ver las dimensiones
o los ejes con la que podía resumir la
información como buscar prácticamente la
dimensión con lo que se podía resumir
las variables como las puedo mostrar y
muchas de las variables que yo
desesperadamente como lo que había ido
había colectado pues puede ser que esté
en función no no solamente por este
factor sino por este parámetro y este
otro y este otro pero al final metía al
análisis y veía que unas cuantas
variables siguieran
estaban relacionados al mostrar los
vectores como el ph de la conductividad
de los sólidos disueltos por otro lado
estaba el oxígeno y así el caudal sube
por otro lado pero también me interesaba
de cómo se relacionaban éstas con los
variables biológicas
y así poder estimar justamente
que la cantidad de agua
es decir q era el factor más importante
que posibilitaba a la estructura de
estas comunidades biológicas pero
ustedes se preguntarán pero para que a
estudiar eso bueno seguro que todos me
han preguntado así en su momento
pero justamente por este proceso del
calentamiento global el retroceso de los
glaciares aquí les muestra una secuencia
de fotografías de como el nevado
chacaltaya se ha ido reduciendo ha ido
mermando la cantidad de agua
muchos de los investigados viven ahí
dependen de esa cantidad agua como los
resultados que había demostrado dependen
de esa cantidad de agua de ese caudal
como lo llamamos en en ecología no así
que a partir de este trabajo que parece
se pocas parecía interesante los sometí
para publicar haciendo ciencia como
científico nos de una manera de evaluar
nos nueva nivel de la productividad que
llegamos a tener
así que en esas épocas ya pudimos
publicar un artículo internacional con
el equipo de trabajo no es que yo lo
hago todos dependemos de un equipo de
trabajo y bueno así vi la influencia que
tenía las características ambientales
respecto a estas comunidades biológicas
este tipo de análisis lo fui realizando
de manera
con los programas que existían en esas
épocas no muchos de estos con licencia
tenía que depender del ofrecimiento de
la cooperación de algún investigador
extranjero que venía que me podía hacer
la copia y no dependía de ese tipo de
cosas más aún si trabajaba con datos
día
bueno luego otra experiencia a partir
del trabajos previos que realicé
me empezaron a invitar a dar a dictar
clases especializar clases tanto en
pregrado como en el posgrado y a partir
de esa experiencia de los software que
utilizaba disponibles hace pocas
enseñaba bioestadística bueno porque le
llamo bioestadística porque es una
manera particular que vemos a la
estadística como tal desde un punto de
vista otro punto de enfoque en realidad
se podría decir seguimos trabajando con
los mismos teoría demás los mismos
algoritmos otro tipo de cosas pero es
más conceptual más filosófico no así que
trataba de enseñar pero también me fui
introduciendo a los programas de código
abierto de estos programas que están
desarrollados por la misma colectividad
científica muchos algunos colegas
desarrollaban paquetes biólogos como tal
que ya dependían afuera en el exterior
de estos de estos códigos así que aparte
de poder enseñar la estadística uno de
los retos era poder utilizar estos
lenguajes informáticos ver la manera
amigable que ellos podía hacer
así que fue un reto doble en realidad
pero porque me dirán bueno estás
perdiendo el tiempo aparte enseñan
estadística les asiste
en la nueva lenguaje de programación
todo eso pero no todo tiene su fin y por
qué porque yo podía hacer fluir mis
ideas en ese momento me di cuenta que
los programas de código cerrado de
licencia eran limitados en cambio los de
código abierto permitía que yo pueda
interactuar lo que sinceramente yo
quería lo que estaba pensando lo podía
tras plasmar acá les muestro justamente
aquí les muestro la relación que existe
de las diferentes regiones que he
llegado a conectar en mosquitos
mosquitos transmisores de la malaria y
el dengue desde la región de los yungas
san borja me digo desde alto de la
región del beni pasando por la región de
los pie de monte de llegar por los
yungas hasta la región de la de la
cumbre y así estas gráficas con una
gráfica en realidad decimos la idea es
poder mostrar
fácilmente al receptor el tipo de
información que yo quiero dar no así por
la migración que podrían tener en las
tortitas más los pedacitos en oscuro de
la cantidad que éstos cambiaban y
afortunadamente sólo llegaban hasta la
región solución casi no pasaban a la
región de la de la cumbre por la región
altiplánica bueno es uno de los
resultados que me ofrecían a hacer
bueno yo había terminado de mis cursos
de pregrado luego postgrado y bueno y
dije bueno bueno en salida de la vida no
termina y hay que seguir continuando hay
que seguir avanzando rescató las
palabras de la primera intervención de
dejaron se acuerdan que su tía le decía
tienes que seguir aprendiendo seguir
aprendiendo así que se me presentó otro
reto en la vida bueno
tuvimos la oportunidad
viajar de extranjero con mi esposa salió
una beca de doctorado nos fuimos a otro
país
al principio parecía cool genial conocer
otra cultura otras otros amigos otros
colegas poder relacionarnos con otra
universidad yo decía genial voy a quedar
ahí voy a nos vamos a establecer
mientras mi esposa estudia mientras yo
cocino mientras yo lavo de todo ese tipo
de cosas pero también decía bueno
también tengo que hacer
informado soy profesional tengo otras
cosas pero en una cosa no es tan simple
no tenía ofertas de trabajo no es que no
podía conseguir había ofertas de trabajo
pero desafortunadamente no eran del
mismo lugar donde estábamos establecidos
ya tenía una niña pequeña y bueno ya era
complicado y tampoco me podía dejar todo
esa carga
a mi esposa bueno esa es espero por el
otro lado decía bueno no me puedo quedar
con los brazos cruzados
bueno y es así con lo que ya sabía
previamente con lo que es el manejo de
datos empecé a ayudar a mi esposa no
estaba en unas universidades más
competitivas dentro del ranking mundial
las de primer a 2020 universidades así
que venía a la casa mi esposa como decía
nuestro amigo constantino con un montón
de quejas cosas hasta sátira tata
pero yo decía que estoy haciendo no aquí
en vez de alejarme de todos estos
problemas tengo que apoyar y con lo que
sabía y era análisis de datos
tratamiento de datos de información con
lo que conocía con todo ese tipo de
insumos que tenía y
para esas épocas llegamos a interactuar
no era el fin el objetivo del estudio de
mi esposa era otra cosa pero estos
programas de código abierto nos puede no
es posible que no solamente información
en la parte competitiva o numérica de
los datos sino también podemos integrar
con estos programas de sistemas de
información geográfica hacíamos mapeo
como ustedes pueden observar ahí en
puntos en azul y en puntos de rojo donde
encontrábamos discrepancia a nivel la
distribución de otros organismos así
habían cosas raras que estaban empezando
a salir en las páginas web en los
portales de data base de datos de bases
públicos había una discrepancia como los
puntos en rojo que los puedo mostrar
respecto a la información que existe de
confiada a los museos respecto la
información que están disponibles en las
bases de datos libres no llega sabían
algo algo lic algoritmos que no podíamos
reconocer qué problema que
automáticamente habían iniciado un punto
que no existía en ese registro y decimos
bueno qué está pasando aquí
y nos nos y así si queríamos extrapolar
identificando sus puntos erróneos en
rojo veíamos que nos podría llevar a
sobreestimar la biodiversidad de algunas
regiones de algunos lugares y esto
podría ser muy mal interpretado si los
llevamos a programas de conservación u
otro tipo de estudios así que parece se
pocas
llegamos a publicar con una introducción
en realidad lo que estaba emergiendo ya
hace unos buenos años atrás sobre el vic
del talón sobre los datos masivos en
manejo de los datos masivos las
librerías que podemos identificar tenían
algunas falencias y propusimos de qué
manera se tenían que corregir este tipo
de datos y que cualquier científico que
trabaja con datos con manejo de datos
que tenga mucho cuidado en el momento de
concluir o sacar a las diferencias sobre
lo que estaba tratando de relacionar
este artículo que puede ser bastante
aburrido tal vez para muchas personas
pero nosotros como científicos nos
evalúan por el impacto que tienen cómo
nos llegan a citar por otros científicos
en otros países y es un artículo que
tiene más citas que hemos tenido muchas
más citas y actualmente sigue ganando
más citas bueno también es el tema
también depende del tema de lo que
llegues a estudiar publicar
y bueno después de eso también empecé a
tener experiencia con el manejo de datos
genómicos es decir a partir de las
secuencias genómicas de los datos bueno
ya no era oro era otro tipo de
información
los laboratorios llegamos a tener
secuencias estos secuencias por
dependiendo el tipo de gen con el y
vamos a trabajar este mi listado de
especies los podía agrupar y relacionar
justamente con las características
genéticas que podían tener
bueno no sale aquí no los clavos más
juntos son claros que están más
agrupados los que está más separados
hacemos una activación evolutiva y luego
podíamos interactuar ver otro tipo de
modelos para ver a nivel de la evolución
de compuestos de alcaloides que podrían
tener estos estos árboles filogenéticos
no era otro tipo de interpretación de
datos ahora se está trabajando mucho con
esto en el campo productivo proyectivo
evolutivo de los órganos organismos pero
bueno con toda la experiencia que ha
aprendido
[Música]
bueno y creo que evolucionado en hacer
ciencia
es decir desde los programas de código
cerrado bajo una licencia ha ido
evolucionando ha ido trabajando pasando
por otros programas ya de código abierto
como el fight obligando al r bueno
lamentablemente no haber llegado
descubrir todavía lo que se prueba se
propone se habla con el programa julia
pero me imagino que es algo que tengo
que seguir aprendiendo que tengo que
seguir indagando porque estos programas
les invito a toda la colectividad a
todos los muchachos que quieres interesa
este tipo de campo en el campo del
lenguaje de la programación que se
puedan introducir porque esto me ha
enseñado a mí y de poder interactuar con
otras ramas del conocimiento no
solamente quedarme con el conocimiento
biológico sino integrar con la parte
bioinformática como ustedes pueden
observar que hoy en día para hacer
ciencia seguro que uno necesita obtenido
necesita tener ese espíritu curioso o no
de poder indagar preguntarse muchas
cosas que todos creo que lo tenemos pero
aparte de ser ciencia seguro nos han
pedido que debemos aprender
otro lenguaje como el como el inglés
justamente para poder interactuar con la
colectividad científica
pero también es importante poder
entender o aprender un lenguaje de
programación esto va a hacer que
nuestras ideas puedan fluir puedan
nuestra nuestra imaginación puedan no
tener límites en realidad como que
queremos mostrar como queremos presentar
en ese sentido
ofrezco les les pido que no seamos más
un ladrillo del sistema de educación son
los temas que me identificado en la
información que me encanta mucho
lleguemos a generar nuevos paradigmas
podemos interactuar con otras ramas del
conocimiento y nos podemos desafiar a
nosotros mismos que no tenemos que que
no tenemos límite podemos hacer muchas
cosas más aún si podemos interactuar con
otras ramas
[Música]
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]